ここにいる皆さんは光について考えたことはありますか
今目の前にも光があります
完全な暗闇でもない限り必ず光があそこに存在していて
関係しています
そして光を考えるうえでとても重要なものがあります
人間が生きる上でとても大切なものです
これがないと人間は人類は発展しませんでした
それは何かというと
対応です
自然界に当たり前のように存在する対応が人間のリズの作っていきました
1日の約半分起きている時間で言うとほとんどの時間空に浮かんでいて
様々な情景をですね地球に降り注いでいます
様々な情景を子宮に作り出しています
例えば
こもれび
夕焼け
虹
オーロラこれは太陽の太陽と地球がおま織りなす
現象ですけども
それから
水面のきらめきであったり
水の波紋です
こういったものの
を
太陽は作り出してくれます
この情景の中には光を考えるうえでとても大事な共通することが含まれています
この中でたくさん共通するものがあるのですが自分が一番
この中で
大切にしていることがあります
それは光には動きがあるということです
時が流れている以上太陽は夜明け前の闇から
夜日が沈むまでですね常に動き続けています
そして
風が吹いて雲が流れて
何が起って雪が降っていっ
米に見えるすべてのものが常に揺れ動いているので小さな家の揺らぎが目に見える
すべての場所に隠されています
光と影が生きているんです
このように泊まっている光
いいえのない光というものはとても自然です
そして光をコントロールすることでもたらす心理状態の変化は太陽が1日の中で動き
続けている
絶えず変化しているということに深く関連しています
太陽が高い位置にあるとき
人間は最も
活動的な
体になります活発な身体になっていきます
真夏の正午の対応は
青白い光を出していいえも強くはっきりと出やすい状態になります
逆に太陽が低い位置にあるときは
人は活動を始めるか活動を収束させる時間帯です
光の色味は赤み帯びて言って明るさも落ちてきます
ただこれはですね
色んな国によって地域によって違いがあります
例えば
赤道直下のアジア圏
赤道直下のアジア圏は太陽が昇っている時間がとても長くて夕日なる時間がすごく短い
です
それによってその空間に
展開する光もこのように蛍光灯がああ
白い蛍光灯がですね空間全体を照らしている例というのがたくさん見られます
それとは反対に例えば夕日の長い
時間がある季節がある北欧などですね
こういったところは空間全体を照らす光というものがとても少なくて小さく温かみの
ある色味を持った光が溢れています
これは1日の対応の動きが無意識にその地域の人々に刷り込まれているという証拠だと
思っています
私はこれが人間の dna に何万年も前から刷り込まれているということを確信して
光を考えるときは必ずこれらのことを参考にしています
そうすると空間の用途に応じて人々の心理状態を整えることが可能になるんです
ここでですね日本人が持っている光の完成について見ていきたいとおもいます
ここに画像でもありますが1930年代に谷崎潤一郎を買いたいん偉いさんという本が
あります
これは江戸時代以前の日本人の持っている感性について陰影に着目して論じている本
です
ちょっとポケットへ戻しますね
例えばですね漆塗りの食器であったり
味噌汁であったりしょうゆであったり洋館であったり
深く吸い込まれそうな鈍い影の中に美を見出していて歴史の艶を感じさせるような濁り
を帯びた光を愛でているというようなことが語られています
西洋ではシャンデリアだったり銀の食器であったり白いクリームであったり
きらめきやはっきりとした陰影を持った
物体に火を求めるという感覚とはまったく違っています
例えば京都の
歴史ある寺院の
ぬレーンの
足の油の染み込んだ
に無違反者のある床材に美しさを感じませんか
おばあちゃんのしわくちゃな顔に時間の流れだけではない何かを感じませんか
家によってそのものが持つ魅力を深めていくということを引き出していくことが日本人
の日にかなうものだと考えています
そして光を丁寧に扱うことで価値をコントロールできるということは歴史が語ってい
ます
昔から例えば神聖なものであったり
神秘的なものであったり
後光がさしてますね
こういったお祭りのような義手的儀式的なものであったり
それから
呪術的なものであったりこういった人々の感情を揺さぶるときにはかならず美しい光か
怪しい闇がそこに溢れていました
昔の人たくさんの ea の技を持っていたんですね
もちろん日本家屋にも光をうまく室内に導く技というものが隠されています
例えば玉砂利です
これは神社仏閣によく見ることができるのですが
にはに敷き詰める白い丸い石のことです
これは防犯という分かりもあったりまあいろんな役割があるんですけれども日本家屋は
軒が深くて昼間でも室内が暗くなりがちなので
太陽の光を十分に取り込むために
これが反射板の役割も持っていました
例えば部屋の奥に鎮座する仏像に金箔が貼られていたのも決してギアギアと見せたかっ
たわけではなくて暗い室内でできるだけ光を受けて
たっぷりとした闇の中で
威厳のある鈍い光を放つためだったんですね
うまく陰影を扱えていたのになぜ
現代の日本人は
こういったものが扱えなくなってしまったんでしょうか
皆さんは光にまつわる言葉というものをどれだけ知っていますか
光の状態を表す言葉というものをどれだけ知っていますか
ちょっと一覧でささっとコピペしたんですけれども
私たちのような
こういったですね光を専門とする職種でもすべての言葉を知っているということはあり
ません
の中で例えば5個ぐらい移民を言葉の読みもわかるよという人はちょっと手を挙げて
もらっていいですか
5秒ぐらい5秒ぐらいで
ちらほらとちらほらといますね
1悪いかだと思います
これらの言葉が漢字だらけで分かりづらいのはそれだけ現代で使われていない証拠かも
しれません
逆にいうと昔の人はちゃんと光のことを考えていて
考えていたということがわかります
そして言葉が失われているということは
文化も失われつつあるということなんではないでしょうか
光は当たり前に存在するものだからこそとても考えにくいものです
ただ光と陰影を上手に扱えるようになればそこにある日を浮かび上がらせることができ
ます
いいえの大切さを知って自ら行動できる人が増えていけば
世界は一気に加速度的に変化して世界が美に溢れていくはずなんです
最後に2015年に実施した
照明と環境を一体化させた自分のプロジェクトを紹介したいと思います
恋逗子海岸ですね浜辺をキャンバスにして夜の弓に人が集まるようにしてほしいという
依頼を受けました
これは光が得意とする元々そこにある環境の価値を高めるということを主題としてお
願いされたプロジェクトです
照らし出す対象としてはあまりにも壮大すぎたんですが
まあこの海という様相ですね分解しまして
海浜波このシンプルな3つの要素からなる
海岸に何か新しい夜の表情を作ることができないかという事で色々と探っていきました
そしてこの中で唯一動きと音のある
波ですね真ん中に見えますけれども白くなっている
コナミに着目して行き着いたのは砕けるシラミの可視化です
それを私はないとウェーブというふうに名付けました
短い映像用意しましたのでご覧ください
もう育てる仕事とともに
糸のように白い光があっ
現れては消えていきます
時として同じ姿を覚えることはありません
照射する光自体はこれは全く羽化してはいない
地球がもたらす素晴らしい景色を浮かび上がらせているだけ
浜辺には一切光が当たらないようにして言えなくしています
波は常に形を変えるので常に移ろう自然光のように
一定ではない光の効果を生み出すことができません
ものようにして丁寧に目から入る情報を整理していくと
じっくりと佇んで感じられる環境ができて
さらにその陰影の先にある隠れた日を感じられることができるんです
皆さんもまずは太陽が生み出す光
それから陰影の美しさに感動するということを思い出してみませんか
そのためには夜がよるらしくあってほしいと思いませんか
ありがとうございました